good evening
allied leaders
have just met to address the
gravest threat to euro-atlantic security
in decades
i invited the nato's coast partners and
sweden and the european union to our
summit
because this crisis affect us all
russia has shattered peace in europe
the people of ukraine are fighting for
their freedom in the face of russia's
unprovoked invasion
we deplore the tragic loss of life
enormous human suffering and destruction
our thoughts
are with those killed
injured
and displaced
we call on russia to stop this senseless
war
immediately
seize
its assaults
we draw all its forces from ukraine
and turn back to the
path of
dialogue and
turn away from aggression
the kremlings the kremlin's objectives
are not limited to ukraine
russia has demanded legally binding
agreements
to announce
further nato enlargement
and remove troops and infrastructure
from allies that joined after 1997.
we are
facing a new normal in european security
where russia openly contests the
european security order
and uses force
to pursue its objectives
the world will hold russia
and belarus accountable for their
actions
russia
as the aggressor
belarus as the enabler
president putin's decision to pursue his
aggression against ukraine
is a terrible strategic mistake
for which russia would pay a severe
price for years to come
nato allies and the european union have
already introduced significant sanctions
and many of our partners around the
globe have joined us
we must stand ready to do more
even if it means
we have to pay a price
because we are in this for a long haul
at the same time
the russian people must know
that kremlin's war on ukraine will not
make russia more secure
it will not make russia more respected
in the world
it will not lead
to a better future for your children
in response to russia's massive military
buildup over the past months we have
already strengthened our deterrence and
defense
yesterday
nato allies
activated our defense plans
and as a result we are deploying
elements of the nato response force
on land
at sea and in the air
to further strengthen our posture
and to respond quickly to any
contingency
the united states
canada and european allies
have deployed thousands or more troops
to the eastern part of the alliance
we have over 100 jets
at high lurch
operating in over 30 different locations
and over
120 ships from the high north
to the mediterranean
including
three strike carrier groups
there must be no space for
miscalculation or misunderstanding
we will do what it takes to protect and
defend every ally
and every inch of nato territory
leaders today also made clear that we
must continue our support to ukraine
the kremlin is trying to make nato and
the eu provide less support to our
partners
so our collective answer must be more
support
to countries like georgia
moldova
and bosnia-herzegovina
to help them succeed
with their democratic reforms
and pursue
the path that they have freely
chosen
more than ever this crisis demonstrates
the importance of north america and
europe standing together in nato
there is no security in europe without a
strong transatlantic bomb
with that i'm ready to take your
questions okay we'll go to algebra
james bay's al jazeera
how fearful are you about the possible
fall of keiv how long in your estimate
in your estimation
can the government of ukraine last and
if we move to a resistance
insurgency type situation what support
can nato then give
so what we see now is a full-fledged
invasion of ukraine
from multiple directions with air sea
and land capabilities
and this is actually in line with what
our intelligence services predicted over
a long period of time because we saw the
build-up
around ukraine with air sea and land
forces
we see of course that they're moving
towards the kiev we also
see
the
rhetoric
the messages
which is strongly indicating that the
aim is to
change government to change
and remove
the democratically elected government in
kiev we are in close contact with the
government of
ukraine
we are
of course monitoring the situation very
closely
um it is still a fluid situation
what we have seen is that um the
ukrainian forces are
fighting bravely and are actually able
to
inflict damage
on the invading russian forces
but again it is
a very fluid and uh and
unevolving situation
nato allies expressed at the
summit today that they
provide support to ukraine they are
ready to continue to broad support
ukraine
uh military support financial support
humanitarian support
and then i think we all have to judge
how things evolves
but the message from
nato leaders and also from
from
from finland and sweden eu
is that we are there to support ukraine
we have support ukraine for many years
and we continue to provide
we'll go to the national press agency
uh mr national news agency of ukraine
secretary general in the current uh
situation which we observe now in
ukraine
does nato uh preserve its uh desire to
assist ukraine with defensive equipment
in particular uh can we
expect that nato will provide ukraine
with so badly needed
anti-aircraft equipment thank you so
much so nato allies continue to provide
the support to ukraine and was actually
at the meeting today at the uh nato
summit with eu and finland sweden
allies announced and also informed other
allies about
the type of weapons the type of support
and some of that also includes air
defense systems
so so nato allies have and continue to
provide support military
but also different types of equipment
to ukraine then we all realize that of
course in this very evolving and
difficult situation it's hard to predict
what would be the
what what what what are the
possibilities in the future
but allies are providing support and are
very committed to continue to provide
support okay we'll go to nbc just behind
the cameras
thank you mr secretary general there's
concern that nato could get pulled into
this conflict if russia were to shut
down electricity or other services uh in
ukraine that could spill over into
poland or romania can you say explicitly
whether a russian cyber attack of that
nature would trigger an article 5
collective defense
so we are sending a very clear message
to russia
that we provide support to our
partner
ukraine and allies provide many
different types of support nato help
ukrainians with their cyber defenses
but then for nato allies we provide the
absolute security guarantees
uh under the washington dt article five
an attack on one will be regarded as
attack on all and we are clear on this
distinction because it is important to
make sure
that
we don't have
an even bigger crisis in europe where a
russia
challenge or is threatening
or attacking any nato allied country and
that's the reason why we so clearly send
a message that we are there to protect
all allies and every inch of nato
territory
when it comes to cyber attacks
uh and the risk for incidents and
excellence
in for instance in in the black sea
we are uh pursuing uh mechanisms of
deconfliction uh to prevent that from
happening
uh we have as nato analysts especially
united states have done that for
instance in syria over a long period of
time and we of course are very focused i
spoke with sakura the
nato supreme commander on that issue
recently and he is very focused on the
need to deconflict to make sure that we
don't have instant accidents that can uh
spiral and get out of control and create
a very dangerous
situation
on cyber
well we have stated that um
cyber attacks can trigger article 5 but
we have never
uh gone into the
position where we give a potential
adversary the privilege of defining
exactly when
we trigger article five
we are focused on strengthening our
cyber defenses we are very much aware of
that that's a risk and
and therefore we are stepping up both
the protection of our cyber networks but
also providing support ukraine and we
are very focused on the need for the
confliction okay we'll go to
npr virtual villages
thank you terry schultz with i'm karen
dw uh i want to know more about the
deployment of the nrf forces please um
how many will be sent where
from where um how long will it take to
get there
thinking about military mobility as
always um and also um what has changed
in your calculation about the threat to
nato territory that has led allies to
make the decision to deploy this for the
first time in history for the purposes
of collective defense thank you
well what has changed over the last
days is of course that there's a
full-fledged invasion of a partner
a country that borders several nato
other countries
and this is the most serious security
crisis we have faced in europe for
decades
and therefore we have the high readiness
force we have the nato response force
and that's the reason why we are
deploying it to
again
prevent any miscalculation and a
misunderstanding
that uh
we are not ready to protect and defend
all allies
and and of course this is something all
allies have agreed to do uh thirteen
hours agreed uh but of course especially
those in eastern part alliance are
extremely concerned
they are close to this uh
uh the fighting in in in ukraine and
they also
border russia and they have seen the not
only the military buildup and
and the ongoing war in ukraine but also
seen the very threatening rhetoric
because this goes far beyond ukraine
this is about how russia is actually
challenging contesting core values for
our security
and demanding that nato
should withdraw all forces
and infrastructure
from almost half of our members
and they stated that if you don't do
that if you don't meet the demands there
will be what they call military
technical consequences so we have to
take this seriously and that's exactly
why
we are now deploying the nato response
force
for the first time
in a collective defense
also
context
and um
and we speak about thousands of troops
we speak about air
and
maritime
capabilities they
are already actually part of the
standing naval groups
we have
many
planes
operating in the eastern part of the
alliance
and then several allies have
partly already assigned troops and
forces to
to the nato response force we have the
lead elements which are led by
by by france we have um
we have the united states which has a
sound assigned thousands of troops to
the nato response force and these will
be deployed to different places in
eastern populace
well there are part of the coming from
the united states but but these are also
very much european troops
uh
for instance the the lead element uh the
vjtf the high readiness joint task force
uh is now led by by by france
there's a strong german component there
and other allies also popular
associated press
lawn cook associated press just to
follow up on that secretary general um
the the uh bjtf can only go to one place
and you have eight allies that are
extremely nervous i mean where where
might you
send it have you identified a particular
weakness
on that eastern flank
but i think we have to understand that
we have many uh
elements uh components of the nato
response force
we have increased the redness of the
nato response force and then i don't
speak only about the lead element or the
vjdf the very high readiness task force
but but but we speak about uh uh
uh more elements than
just that one second we have allies
uh the united states but also not
kingdom and other allies that have
increased readiness of forces
uh that are assigned to nato and the
nato response force
so of course these are additional forces
that we can deploy as part of the
broader deployment of the nato response
force i'm not saying that we are
deploying the whole force the size of
the nato response force has been tripled
since 2014 to roughly 40 000 troops
i'm not saying we're deploying the whole
thing i'm saying that we are deploying
elements elements of the leader
of the vjtf and elements of the rest of
the nato response force and uh and then
it is for sakura to make fine decisions
exactly where the different elements are
deployed but we activated the defense
plans yesterday
and and
now
the elements
of this force will be deployed
is being deployed
okay we'll go to tv2
maybe
later
norway
i'll just follow up on ap and what terry
from npr said
how
quick can these uh troops
and this force be
deployed
but some of these forces are already
operating because we have sea and air
forces which are also all the part of
the nato maritime forces operating from
the banksia down to the mediterranean
some are air forces
the air component of the nato response
force
and then some of the land forces are
also can move within a few days
because they are part of either the lead
element um which has already high
redness or the other elements that has
been put on high redness
so we speak about base and some are all
they
operating
because we have increased our presence
already
okay we'll try to take a couple of
questions online uh we'll go first to
frankfurt algebra
thanks a lot uh good afternoon secretary
general in the statement that has just
been released
um it is said that uh russia's actions
are flagrant rejection of the principles
was fined in the nato-russia pounding
act
and then it continues it is russia that
has walked away from its commitments
under the act
does
that mean that nato now considers the
nato-russia founding act as obsolete
or do nato member states still
are they still bound do they still feel
bound by this document thanks a lot
nato leaders decided today a statement
very clearly state
the fact that russia has walked away
the nato-russia founding act
is based on some core principles and
shrine in the final founding act and
that is
the respect for uh
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
all uh
countries including of course ukraine
and this has been violated not once but
twice
and has actually constantly violated
violated since 2014 with the illegal
annexation of crimea and the continued
presence of russian forces and
russian-backed separatists in eastern
ukraine donbass and this is further
violated
with the full fledge generation of
ukraine that you have seen over the last
couple of days
um so so so what we have what we see
is that russia show no respect for the
nato russia founding act and of course
if you have a founding act between two
partners
nato and russia and one part doesn't
respect that agreement that the
agreement doesn't work
it doesn't function it doesn't
help us to improve our relationship with
the with with russia because even if the
founding act has good provisions and
and good intentions
if these uh intentions and the
provisions and the and the founding act
is not respected it doesn't work so
that's the reality the nato for uh nato
russia funding act uh
doesn't work because one side russia has
violated it over many years but now is
here
uh
extremely
uh blatant uh
and flagrant and flagrant violation of
the funding out with the invasion of
ukraine
we'll take the next question online also
from greg palket from fox
thank you
mr secretary general uh two quick
questions one about war one about peace
do you agree with some reports of
intelligence officials that kiev could
fall within the next
day or two and despite the bravery of
the fighting that you have cited among
ukrainian soldiers
you see a defeat inevitable if war goes
on and the quick question about peace
there is discussion
of president zielinski offering to
discuss with
russia
an approach to peace that might include
neutrality for
ukraine would you agree to something
like that
the first on the situation
on the ground
um it is a full invasion of ukraine
they are moving towards kiev
and the stated goal is to
change the government of ukraine
it is a very
unpredictable situation therefore i'm
not re
speculate but i will pay my respect
to the
ukrainian armed forces
which are really
proving their bravery and
their courage by
fighting and standing up against
the
much larger invading russian force
on potential talks between
um the government of ukraine uh
president zielenski and uh and russia
my main message is that this is for
president zelinski and the government of
ukraine to decide
uh
what we
what we need to see now is that russia
stop
the attack against ukraine that they
withdraw their forces and seize
uh all the attacks on ukraine that's the
the easiest the fastest and the best way
to peace
so if they want
peace then it's just stop to attack
ukraine
and if we call on russia to do exactly
that
okay
yes
from ntv secretary general two short
questions first you're a statistician
and so far with regard the risk you have
already evaluated
the the risk and the threat against nato
coming from russia particularly you you
foresee the playbook of russia and so my
first question is
what is the risk that this conflict
spread
where and what might be the end goal of
russia and my second question is you
have at the top of your the tip of your
fingers
the security of one billion
citizen in the transatlantic area so you
met with on btc all the leaders can you
reassure the public opinion that
if there is a genuine threat coming from
because the rhetoric the aggressive
rhetoric of russia
its behavior is acceptable that all
member states are committed to defend
and protect every single centimeter of
nato thank you
in the meeting today with nato leaders
uh
it was a very strong
message of unity a very strong message
of the soul that we need to stand
together
uh not only in words but also in deeds
so we agreed a strong statement
calling on russia to stop
the attacks on ukraine to withdraw its
forces
but also
we agreed to continue to provide support
to ukraine and also continue to
strengthen our presence in eastern part
alliance
to prevent
any attack on any nato allied country
we have a defensive presence in the east
we
are
increasing our presence not to provoke a
conflict but to prevent the conflict and
as long as there is no doubt about
nato's readiness to protect and defend
all our eyes
and our commitment to the core message
the core task of nato one for all for
one an attack on one ally will be
regarded as attack on all
then no ally will be attacked and that
will prevent the conflict
uh and that will preserve peace for nato
allies and for one billion people
um and and that's the reason why we
communicate so clearly and that's the
reason why we are deploying more troops
in the eastern part of the islands
to make sure that there is no
possibility to misunderstand
uh awareness to protect and defend all
allies and again this is to pressure
peace
to prevent an attack
and to prevent that the war which is
going on in ukraine
um
spill over to any nato other country
and uh and that's that that was the
message from nato leaders today
uh that was also the message when i met
with many of them in the g7
uh yesterday
and that is also of course a message uh
when we speak to close partners finland
sweden and the european union uh because
we all are concerned and russia's attack
on ukraine is
more than an attack on ukraine is that
it's a devastating horrendous attack on
innocent
uh
people in ukraine but is also an attack
on the whole european security order and
that's the reason why you take it so
extremely seriously
thank you alex
secretary general one question on on
ukraine's request
for turkey to to close the prosperous to
for russian warships does that be and
what's that disguise and one follow up
on questions asked um we heard uh today
from the lithuanian foreign minister
saying that when we lose ukraine today
we will be fighting for nato later
would you say that the statement is
exaggerated
thank you
so on on the posters that was not an
issue
on
the uh
the potential attack on any potential
attack related to other country well
awesome
that has been my message throughout the
whole day that was the message from the
nato leaders in the summit today
is that is that is that we are there to
protect and defend all ours nato is the
strongest military alliance in the world
and make no mistake we are there to
protect and defend all eyes and every
inch of nato territory and we convey
that message again and again
both in words but also in deeds
and the and that's the way to prevent
the war that's the one to prevent an
attack to pursue peace and we have done
so for more than 70 years and we'll
continue to do it also in the light of
the attack on
ukraine
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference
oh